you guys married how long six years wow
what's your ethnicity I'm assuming
you're not eating because no Indian
woman's waiting those six years you're
Indian how are you for almost six years
with no ring
that's not a reason you've been in
school what are you majoring in patience
six years a long time what's
hesitation dude what's holding you up
just said well
you are terrified on the inside and you
should be how old are you you're in your
50s ah second marriage got it okay there
it is am I right I told you I'm
good at this hey I don't do this but
nobody I mean you guys said 15 he
hesitate to get married he had half his
money taken from him already one time